valentina lo que usted decía hasta ahora
muy peleado ese primer lugar entre los
demócratas cristianos cdu
y los socialdemócratas por lo tanto
ambos candidatos se reivindican con
posibilidades de formar coalición los
alemanes se lo esperaban no es cierto
desde hace tres meses cuatro meses que
se viene hablando de que ese primer
lugar estaba muy peleado lo cierto que
aquí lo más importante ha sido
participar hoy vimos una gran afluencia
los locales de votación se calcula que
un tercio del electorado además ya había
enviado por adelantado su voto a través
del correo así que la democracia cosa de
muy buena salud en este país donde se
espera que la participación ronde cerca
del 80 por ciento esos datos todavía no
tenemos pero eran las estimaciones y es
lo que nos parece que pese incluso aquí
en berlín que había la maratón de la
ciudad las personas asistieron a votar
lo importante es participar y mantener
en buena salud esta democracia que como
ustedes saben es bien particular porque
es una democracia parlamentaria
indirecta los electores no votan
directamente al la canciller sino que
votan a los parlamentarios que van a
elegir no cierto el jefe de gobierno
erika recordemos que tenemos los
terceros resultados a boca de urna que
le dan un 25 2% a los socialdemócratas
un 24,6 por ciento a los conservadores y
un 14,3 por ciento a los verdes pero
cuando empezarán a emitirse los
resultados de manera oficial es posible
que estos comicios quedan definidos hoy
mismo
si efectivamente a la medianoche se
conocen los resultados oficiales pero un
poquito antes dentro de algunas horas se
reúnen los principales líderes de los
partidos en un programa de televisión de
la televisión pública y allí ya comienza
a vislumbrarse lo que puede ser ese
juego de alianzas que como hemos dicho
desde la posguerra por primera vez se
asume que va a ser un gobierno
tripartito así que como hemos dicho
también muchas veces la canciller merkel
va a seguir en el gobierno dentro de
algunas semanas todavía porque es
necesario ver cómo se va a constituir
finalmente ese gobierno alemán ninguna
última palabra está dicha valentina
todavía hay muchas posibilidades en esta
noche electoral alemana erika usted
muchas gracias por toda esta información
desde berlín